[Music]
this is what remains of a un logistics
base in goma in north kivu province
thousands of congolese protesters
chanted anti-un's slogans demanding the
peacekeeping mission leave the country
they threw stones looted office
equipment and other material
even the peacekeepers stationed inside
and local police could not control the
crowd
[Music]
people are dying every day in the north
in beni and in ituri province in the
presence of monasco
the peacekeepers have said they are
unable to keep people safe to ensure the
continued implementation the deputy
spokesman for the un mission says
everything is being done to minimize
disruption to its work the mission is
activating additional security protocols
and advancing contingency planning to
ensure the continued implementation of
its mandate and the secure the safety
and security of all un personnel
the relationship between some congolese
and the un has been tense at best the
protesters say the un has failed to
protect them from frequent attacks
the u.n peacekeeping mission in the
democratic republic of congo has heard a
presence here for more than 20 years
despite this more than a hundred rebel
groups in the east control the vast
region that is rich in minerals
we will respect our commitment with
monucco but we should also avoid any
speech or declarations likely to create
mistrust
such altercations are not new in 2019
there were riots in the territory of
beni several people were killed and un
property was destroyed to this date
residency the u.n the national army and
other foreign troops have failed to stop
the violence
many congolese say they are tired they
want peace and if the u.n cannot provide
stability than its forces need to leave
catherine soy al jazeera